tal como estaba previsto se instalaron
dos asambleas nacionales el día de hoy
en venezuela la elegida el pasado 6 de
diciembre donde el gran polo patriótico
tendrá la mayoría absoluta tomó la sede
del hemiciclo esta mañana y fue
acondicionada con 227 curules para
recibir a los nuevos diputados la junta
directiva del año 2020 2021 le aparecerá
jorge rodríguez ex ministro de
comunicación de nicolás maduro los
nuevos parlamentarios entraron al
palacio legislativo con los cuadros de
chávez y de simón bolívar para
exhibirlos en el sitio donde desde ahora
se harán las sesiones para aprobar las
leyes entretanto el líder opositor juan
guaidó también hizo la instalación de
otra directiva de la asamblea nacional
apegándose una continuidad para extender
su mandato como jefe el parlamento por
un año más
eeuu ayer le dio un espaldarazo a esta
decisión en su discurso insistió que
deben hacerse unas nuevas elecciones
presidenciales y llamó a los otros
líderes opositores que no están de
acuerdo con sus lineamientos entre ellos
enrique capriles maría corina machado a
que se acerquen para trabajar en función
a la patria en horas tempranas de la
mañana
por las redes sociales con fotos que
funcionaron visiblemente armados de la
dirección general de contrainteligencia
militar rodeaban su vivienda sobre el
político pesan amenazas de cárcel por
haber extendido las funciones de la
asamblea nacional que fue electa en 2015
lo que para el chavismo implica un
delito de usurpación de funciones